regarde la télévision en baisse les yeux
quand on va au cinéma on lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 8 décembre au
royaume-uni place à l'antidote la
campagne de vaccination contre le coc
vide a débuté ce matin l'euro paie la
passe le cap des 20 millions de cas et
offre un visage contrasté l'exception
suédoise touche à sa fin nouvelles
mesures de restriction au canada ou en
allemagne qui faisait jusqu'ici figure
d'exemple pour sa gestion de la crise
quant à la france me confiner elle est
encore loin d'atteindre ses objectifs
alors l'europe épicentre de l'épidémie
est telle dans l'impasse quelle
stratégie pour sortir de cette deuxième
vague
nous en parlerons avec nos invités notre
avenir énergétique et écologique passe
par le nucléaire emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui déclarations lors de sa
visite dans l' usine de framatome au
creusot le futur porte-avions français
sera à propulsion nucléaire précise le
président un déplacement symbolique
alors qu'il ya presque cinq ans l'accord
de paris sur le climat était adopté la
proposition ne convainc pas celles de
deux députés de doter le parlement d'un
véritable pouvoir de contrôle sur les
exportations d'armes de la france selon
une note gouvernementale citée par
disclose l'exécutif doit s'opposer à
tout contrôle qui risquerait de nuire à
la crédibilité des engage
monde la france et à sa capacité à
exporter
[Musique]
il
c'est donc une toute première dans un
pays occidental le royaume uni a débuté
depuis ce matin ses vaccinations
contrôle kobe 19
les premières doses du vaccin des
laboratoires de l'alliance américano
allemande fader biotech ont été
distribués et les 800000 premières doses
sont destinées aux personnes
hospitalisées de plus de 80 ans sic au
personnel des maisons de retraite et aux
soignants
les détails avec françois this kiewit ch
sous les applaudissements des soignants
et les flashes des photographes
margaret keenan 90 printemps est devenue
la première occidental à recevoir un
vaccin contre le nouveau coronavirus
[Musique]
c'était bien c'était bien je n'étais pas
du tout inquiète c'était vraiment bien
oui je vous dirais de foncer allez-y
parce que c'est gratuit et c'est la
meilleure chose qui soit arrivée pour le
moment alors allez-y c'est ce que je
vous dis si je peux le faire vous le
pouvez aussi pays européen le plus
endeuillé par la pandémie
le royaume-uni le premier au monde à
avoir donné son feu vert début décembre
au déploiement du vaccin des
laboratoires de l'alliance américano
allemande
pfizer bio ntech une campagne de
vaccination crucial pour le gouvernement
de boris johnson
très critiquée sur sa gestion de la
pandémie ce niveau ce matin en ce moment
même partout en écosse en irlande du
nord au pays de galles en angleterre les
gens reçoivent le vaccin pour la
première fois et progressivement cela
fera une énorme différence
mais je dis bien progressivement parce
que vous savez nous n'y sommes pas
encore nous n'avons pas encore vaincu ce
virus c'est très important que les gens
le comprennent on ne peut pas se
permettre de baisser la garde
maintenant donc mon message serait le
suivant c'est incroyable de voir ce
vaccin c'est incroyable de voir cette
formidable avancée pour toutes les
nations
on ne peut pas se permettre de baisser
la garde maintenant faudra au total 40
millions de doses du vaccin fighters ont
été commandées par le gouvernement
britannique permettant de protéger
environ 20 millions de personnes car
deux injections sont nécessaires à trois
semaines d'intervalle
depuis ce mardi 50 hôpitaux commencé à
administrer les premières 800 mille
doses et 1000 centres de vaccination
seront créés selon le ministère de la
santé avec la priorité donnée aux
résidents et employés des maisons de
retraite ainsi qu aux soignants et aux
plus de 80 ans
j'ai été vacciné lui environ 15 minutes
donc j'étais le premier soignants à le
recevoir apparemment c'est comme
n'importe quel autre injection vous
savez je le ressens encore aucun effet
secondaire mais cela ne fait que 15 20
minutes mais je ne m'attends pas en
ressentir la majorité de la population
britannique
devra attendre quant à elle 2021 et pour
convaincre les plus sceptiques
la reine élisabeth 94 ans et son époux
le prince philip 99 ans seront vaccinés
prochainement selon la presse anglo
saxonne et il pourrait même le faire en
public alors l'europe épicentre de
l'épidémie est telle dans l'impasse en
dépit des efforts de tous les pays rien
ne semble pouvoir arrêter la circulation
du virus quelle stratégie pour sortir de
cette deuxième vague et ne pas en
affronter une troisième place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités et pour en
parler nous sommes avec bertrand legrand
médecins généralistes laurent alex en
chine revient et céistes françois cocq
et céistes eu aussi bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france le
royaume uni qui devient donc le premier
pays occidental à vacciner massivement
première injection
ce matin du vexin pfizer alors que la
campagne de vaccination en france a on
le rappelle ne va pas démarrer avant au
moins un mois vous diriez que les
anglais se débrouillent mieux que nous
docteur legrand au je dirais messieurs
les anglais tirez les premiers
c'est merveilleux commencé vais
commencer c'est à dire c'est avec de
l'ironie
vous avez essuyé les plâtres messieurs
les anglais m'ont contraire commencer
tant mieux pour vous allez pouvoir
revivre normalement avant nous c'est
dans les deux sens c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous en france
j'espère que les anglais sont mieux
informés mais nous en france en tant que
médecin généraliste on n'a reçu aucune
étude aucune formation sur la pharmaco
surfant sur la manière dont a été
construit le vaccin est donc on n'est
pas au courant des possibles effets
secondaires ou des possibles bénéfices
et donc moi je suis plutôt quelqu'un qui
préfère les vaccins mais de manière
générale mais
je ne prescrit pas un médicament sans en
connaître dit son mode de fonctionnement
dit les bénéfices risques alors bien sûr
on peut pas attendre d'avoir une étude
pour en évaluer le bénéfice risque on
aimerait bien avoir des pharmacologues
qui nous donnent ce qu'ils gens savent
et ceux qu'ils en espèrent
or aujourd'hui moi je n'ai pas entendu
françois cocq le royaume uni veut
montrer qu'il est plutôt à la pointe où
c'est l'europe qui a un train de retard
on rentrera justement dans le détail
deux de ces études et du scepticisme
dans quelques instants mais vous vous
êtes dans quel état d'esprit justement
ce jour de grande première pour nos amis
britanniques
je considère que c'est pas tant d'un
point de vue sanitaire que d'un point de
vue politique que c'est une grande
première pour le royaume-uni chacun
comprend bien et ça vient d'être
explicitée par pas par des sachants et
des gens qui sont plus à même que moi de
le dire
d'un point de vue sanitaire et d'un
point de vue de la sécurité que si le
royaume uni avancent aussi vite c'est
pas forcément qu'il a beaucoup plus de
garanties que nous pouvons avoir
aujourd'hui mais sans doute parce que sa
gestion de crise alors celle là gestion
de crise française et assez calamiteuse
et j'imagine que nous y reviendrons dans
les minutes qui viennent
mais la gestion de crise au royaume uni
était pour le moins très perfectible et
elle a posé de gros soucis temps lors de
la première vague que lors de cette
deuxième vague et monsieur johnson très
clairement essayé de marquer et de faire
un coup politique
en avançant la vaccination en étant l'un
des premiers à la proposer à sa
population
vous comprenez il ya un enjeu en termes
de déconfinement de relance de
l'économie
mais l'équilibré entre le sanitaire et
économique et la politique il n'est pas
sûr qu'il soit atteint en la matière et
peut-être que monsieur johnson brûlures
quelques étapes alors on va essayer d'y
voir plus clair sur le fait de comment
se fait-il que le royaume uni qui fait
toujours partie officiellement de rappel
un de l'union européenne ait pu lancer
sa campagne de vaccination au congo
vivent 19 et landry d'ailleurs qui suit
la même voie en ayant acquis la semaine
dernière le vexin russes la réponse tout
de suite en images avant d'autoriser un
vaccin sur leur territoire les pays
membres de l'ue
européenne doivent normalement attendre
l'aval de la commission européenne qui
elle-même reçoit le feu vert de
l'autorité européenne des médicaments
les 27 s'étaient mis d'accord pour que
la commission signant leur nom des pré
commandes de vaccins six contrats ont
été conclus avec six laboratoires le
royaume uni et la hongrie ont décidé de
contourner cette procédure centralisée
et de faire appel à la procédure
d'urgence
ils peuvent donc testé et approuvé eux
mêmes un vaccin pour une durée limitée
le royaume uni est le premier pays
occidental à déployer un accent sur son
territoire c'est aussi le pays européen
qui compte le plus de morts dus qu'aux
vite 19 près de 61 mille cinq cents
contrairement à ce qu'a affirmé le
ministre de la santé britannique matt
hancock
c'est bien cette procédure d'urgence qui
a été utilisée puisque le droit européen
reste en vigueur dans ce pays jusqu'au
31 décembre 2020 malgré le break site
la hongrie a choisi en novembre de
commander des échantillons du vaccin
russe spoutnik v qui ne fait pas partie
des pré commandes de la commission
européenne après examen budapest
importera des quantités plus importantes
le mois prochain et envisage même une
production par un fabricant hongrois
docteur laurent alexandre les anglais
qui ont donc donné ainsi on comprend
bien des autorisations d'urgence ils ont
en quelque sorte accélérer le protocole
votre réaction
alors on peut dire de choses pour reed
johnson
c'est un pari il fait un pari sur la
base des données qui sont actuellement
disponibles
1 les vaccins arn la nouvelle
technologie pour s'est rapidement des
vaccins sur les malades qui ont reçu le
vaccin à peu près 45 mille ont reçu le
vaccin est à peu près autant ont reçu le
placebo
on n'a pas noté d'effets secondaires
graves on a noté des petites rougeurs
ddd fatiguée un petit peu de fièvre mais
pour l'instant rien de grave mais on n'a
que deux mois de retard de deux reculs
bien évidemment donc le pari qui est
fait par ce boris johnson c'est que les
données dont on dispose on sur les
nouveaux virus permettent de généraliser
la vaccination dans un pays entier c'est
un vrai pari qui a une dimension
médicale mais qui a aussi une dimension
économique
en même temps que le lancement de cette
opération de vaccination massive par les
nouveaux vaccins
johnson doit faire face à une opposition
importante dans l'union européenne sur
les modalités de bréxent it qui l'avait
envisagé le plus probable c'est que le
break site va finir par se faire mais
pas du tout aux conditions économiques
avaient envisagé l'angleterre autrement
dit ça va beaucoup tangué en angleterre
au premier et au deuxième semestre de
l'année 2021 boris johnson ne veut pas
avoir de front c'est à dire à la fois
une baisse de l'économie à cause du
break site
et puis une baisse de l'économie à cause
de la deuxième puis de la troisième
vague qui est inévitable si l'on ne
vaccinent pas relativement rapidement
donc oui c'est une décision politique
c'est un arbitrage politique mais c'est
ça la politique
on a le choix entre ne prendre aucun
risque et vacciner les gens en 2060
quand on aura 40 ans de recul avec ces
vaccins ou de les vacciner plus vite en
prenant un risque médical puisque
effectivement nous n'avons aujourd'hui
que entre deux et trois mois de recul
c'est ça la politique et c'est ce qu'a
fait boris johnson je trouve que il
prend un vrai risque d'être le premier à
lancer une vaccination de masse
mais c'est peut-être lui qui tirera les
marrons du feu en premier parce que il
va peut-être cassé le premier la
deuxième et la troisième vague hugo vide
et pouvoir relancer l'économie en
premier ce qui est fondamental pour lui
je le répète parce que pour le port pour
ce qui concerne le break site pour
l'instant ça ne se passe pas très bien
et l'association d'un mauvais breakes
site ou d'un break site sand il est en
même temps d'une reprise importante des
contaminations qu'ovide serait
absolument catastrophique serait
mortifère pour la carrière politique de
boris johnson docteur le grand laurent
alexandre dit voilà il a quand même pris
un risque donc vous êtes tous d'accord
sur un acteur également politique il
n'empêche salins j'aime bien seul parce
que par rapport à la france 23 % des
britanniques n'ont pas confiance dans ce
vaccin contre un français sur deux
comment on explique un tel écart parce
que finalement les britanniques ont
l'air d'y aller voilà plutôt joyeuse
mans se faire vacciner alors c'est assez
étonnant que des gens se prononce pour
ou contre le vaccin
moi j'ai personnellement je vous le
redis en tant que médecin on m'a jamais
appris la pharmacologie pendant toutes
mes années de médecine
donc quand je prends une décision sur
l'utilisation d'un médicament ou d'un
vaccin je le fais sur la base d'études
cliniques ou quand on a pas d'étude
clinique ou quand on en a pas assez de
recul sur la base de la spécialité des
pharmacologues c'est le pharmacologue
qui a la vision complète du risque et du
bénéfice
suite à la sortie d'une nouvelle
molécule ou la sortie d'une dame nouvel
anticorps qui va permettre de lutter
contre le contre local vide le problème
c'est que ces fermes à colog ne sont pas
sur vos antennes n'ont pas beaucoup
publié et d'aimer laboratoires
pharmaceutiques eux mêmes devraient
peut-être assuré meilleure information
des médecins généralistes qui se vont
être en première ligne donc c'est défaut
d'information il est problématique parce
que comment voulez vous qu'on défende
quoi que ce soit si on ne sait même pas
comment agit le ac100 c'est un vrai
problème pour nous alors j'espère que
des professeurs eux ont vu les études
avant de valider ça mais effectivement
c'est un risque politique important pour
vos rides johnson parce que c'est un
effet aux noces sur quelque chose qu'on
ne comprend pas françois comme vous
votre réaction parce que l'on parle du
royaume uni qui n'auraient pas eu
voilà accès aux informations on nous dit
pourtant que les agences de santé sur
place à travailler peut-être plus vite
les français c'est ce qu'on entend ici
ou là on ne saura peut-être pas la
vérité mais ça vous inspire quoi nous
nous sommes en retard les français l
afficheur nous le dit lui même le
monsieur avec sein du gouvernement qu'il
n'a pas encore les études effectivement
nécessaire il n'y a pas eu accès en tout
cas il ya deux aspects d'abord
concernant le royaume uni je ne crois
pas que monsieur ben johnson finalement
prennent un risque parce que lui
politiquement il est en échec
il a en échec sur la crise la gestion de
la crise kovi kovi dit là en échec sur
la gestion du brésil et d'une certaine
façon il n'a plus grand chose à perdre
par contre ceux à qui fait prendre un
risque c'est sa population il fait un
pari mais ce qu'ils encourent le risque
ce n'est pas lui et son gouvernement se
sont directement les britanniques qui
actuellement sont en train de se faire
de se faire vacciner ou pas en fonction
de ce qu'il en est mais on n'est pas à
même aujourd'hui de le juger
par contre ce qu'on est capable de dire
d'un point de vue politique c'est que
pour pouvoir lancer une opération assez
large et à ses fastes de vaccination il
faut un accord populaire il faut du
consentement populaire et nous autres
français nous voyons bien que dans notre
pays
ce consentement populaire cette adhésion
pour se faire vacciner est détruite
elle est détruite elle a été arasée
depuis des années d'abord parce qu'on a
vu le poids des lobbys pharmaceutiques
et la manière dont ils étaient bien
reçus dans les alcôves des palais
présidentiels et dont ils pouvaient
jouir d'une forme d'immunité
et puis parce qu'on nous a trop menti
depuis la début de la crise qu vide on a
eu le mensonge sur les masques on a eu
le mensonge sur les tests on aime le
mensonge sur la manière dont le
déconfinement c'est s'est passé et le
constat est aujourd'hui et que les
choses vont de mal de mal en pis mal
gérée qu'ailleurs oui pas alors vous
avez aussi une responsabilité sur les
plateaux de télé on a beaucoup commenté
eux les déclarations ce matin du
professeur éric comme un chef
c'est pas n'importe qui en chef du
service des maladies infectieuses et
tropicales à l'hôpital parisien de la
pitié-salpêtrière il était interrogé
pour savoir s'il allait oui ou non se
faire vacciner écoutez sa réponse oui je
me ferai vacciner mais avec les 2 qui
arrive pour l'instant je ne sais pas ce
que ça vous sur les vaccins à base d'ail
rem et
vu me vacciner avec des produits que je
ne connais pas c'est leur faire une
confiance aveugle et absolue et laurent
alexandre revient toujours à la même
chose voilà on ne connaît pas on n'a pas
lu les les études c'est ça qui nourri le
scepticisme des français ou plutôt la
défiance qu'ils ont envers les autorités
finalement alors non il ya une défiance
spécifique à la france même si la france
est le pays de pasteur
c'est qu'il y a un fort courant anti
vaccins qui s'est développée depuis
quelques années qui plus faible dans
d'autres pays même s'il est présent dans
tous les pays développés
d'ailleurs ce refus du vaccin il varie
d'une région à l'autre par exemple en
suisse il y à une acceptation très forte
du vaccin dont la zone francophone et
dans la zone italophone en revanche il
ya une méfiance très importante contre
les vaccins dans la zone de la suisse
germanophone
donc on a à l'intérieur des pays et
entre les pays des grosses variations
dans l'acceptation de la vaccination
la france est un des pays où il ya le
plus de méfiance contre la vaccination
mais il faut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre de leaders d'opinion qui ont dit
des horreurs sur la vaccination
notamment récemment par exemple docteur
foucher qui est très médiatique qui est
souvent sur les plateaux de télévision a
expliqué il ya trois jours à marseille
dans une réunion publique et la vidéo
est disponible sur youtube
quand vaccinant les gens dans les
personnes âgées dans les ehpad le
gouvernement était en train d'organiser
le génocide de nos seniors le génocide
de nos personnes âgées
quand vous avez quelqu'un d'aussi connu
à la télé que l'est le docteur foucher
et qu'il explique que le gouvernement
organise le génocide de nos vieux
parents en les vaccinant dans les ehpad
vous imaginez que ça a un effet
catastrophique donc oui des gens
irresponsables qui tiennent des propos
de cette nature là dans les médias sont
de nature en france a expliqué une
partie de l'excès de méfiance en france
par rapport à la vaccination
mais ce que dit eric comme est tout à
fait raisonnable
c'est vrai que nous ne connaissons pas
tous sur les nouveaux vaccins
moi je n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts et
je ne
je touche d'argent d'aucun fabricants de
vaccins mais je suis très favorable aux
vaccins et je pense que compte tenu de
la crise économique en cours
il faut qu'on intègre le petit risque
que nous prenons en vaccinant aux hits
avec le gros risque qu'on a
d'un point de vue économique il faut
aussi voir les petits commerçants qui
vont se suicider parce qu'ils auront
fait faillite en 2021
les restaurateurs qui vont des prix mais
qui vont se liguer la la baisse de la
production est très importante pour
l'instant l'état paye tout et on ne se
rend pas compte mais en 2021 l'état va
cesser de subventionner massivement
l'économie et donc on va avoir une vraie
baisse du niveau de vie et de la
richesse des gens donc il faut intégrer
cette dimension économique parce qu'il
n'ya pas que le risque qu'on prend avec
les vaccins et je le répète moi je suis
très favorable au nouveau vaccin
irène et personnellement je me ferai
vacciner par ces nouveaux vaccins à arn
le plus tôt possible quand ils seront
disponibles mais il ne faut pas oublier
qu'il ya à côté de ce petit risque
un énorme risque qui lui est avéré c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui craquent il ya des
gens qui en ont marre du confinement il
ya des étudiants qui sont en train de
bousiller une deuxième année et puis qui
déprime dans l'eure dans leurs cités
universitaires déserté que même pas le
droit d'aller à la bibliothèque
universitaire donc il ya des dégâts
psychologiques importants il ya des
vieux qui meurent sans avoir vu leurs
familles parce qu'on peut pas on veut
pas contenir jusqu'à demain c'est pas
demain la veille pardonnez-moi laurent
alexandre l'a compris l'idée c'est pas
demain la veille réseau si on commence à
piquer à tour de bras au royaume uni en
europe et bien ça se corse à on entendu
jerôme seine au moins annoncer des
mauvaises nouvelles
hier exemple aussi de l'allemagne on
disait que c'était un exemple pour
l'europe il n'empêche il y à de
nouvelles restrictions en bavière comme
paris d'ailleurs berlin qui peinent à
endiguer cette seconde vague du cornât
virus comme nous l'expliquent pitard
oliver et on vous reprend pour les
réactions après messieurs angela merkel
la chancelière allemande ainsi aller
plus loin que les restrictions locales
mises en place région par région
mais la constitution allemande ne permet
pas vraiment à la chancelière au
gouvernement fédéral d'imposer une
politique
c'est une décision qui revient au
gouvernement des 16 régions
la bavière a prolongé son état d'urgence
et mis en place de nouvelles mesures
comme l'interdiction de la vente
d'alcool dans les espaces publics
bavarois la saxe a également adopté des
mesures plus contraignantes en saxe les
écoles et jardins d'enfants et presque
tous les commerces ont dû fermer après
avoir enregistré quasiment 6000 cas de
kobe 19 en un week end pour un total
dans cette région d'un peu plus de
soixante dix mille cas certains souhaité
un confinement nationale c'est une
proposition qui est en cours de
discussion plus haut niveau avec la
fermeture des écoles le 14 décembre
jusqu'au 10 janvier des vacances
prolongées pour les écoles et les
jardins enfants mais également la mise
en place de règles plus strictes sur les
lieux les jauges des interactions
sociales
c'est cependant une question épineuse
tout d'abord ces mesures coïnciderait
avec les vacances de noël et risquerait
d'être profondément impopulaires d'autre
part cela nécessiterait l'accord des 16
heures
allemande pour un confinement d'une
telle ampleur cela semble peu probable
en raison des répercussions économiques
en résumé même si certains demandent la
mise en place de restrictions uniformes
pour toute l'allemagne
il reste à voir si cela est possible
dans tous les cas certains états
prennent déjà des mesures de leur côté à
laon en allemagne on s'interroge sur
leur confinement plus de 20 millions de
carats en europe c'est normal qu'on
durcisse le ton on prend les bonnes
mesures docteur le grand oui je pense
que à la veille de noël alors que ça va
être la plus grande fiesta je dirais
dans le en europe
faut bien comprendre que on n'est pas
face à 20 à 30% des français qui vont
faire la fête comme au mois d'août bas
on est face à 60 millions de français
qui vont se réunir certes dans des
petites réunions mais donc l'effet de
autant de petites réunions est un
accélérateur à que vides absolument
phénoménale dont on n'a encore jamais
connu un tel ou telle ampleur et penser
que ces réunions n'auront pas lieu
relève de la stupidité absolue donc le
seul moyen qu'on a d'éviter l'une veut
une troisième vague qui va partir d'un
plateau plus haut que la deuxième c'est
de baisser ce plateau donc normalement
on devrait être dans la période de
quatre semaines qui précèdent ou on
teste un maximum de personnes où on
isole efficacement tout le foyer dans
lequel il y à une personne malade parce
que je suis désolé mais quand il
faudrait une personne malade elle va
contaminer l'ensemble de son foyer et
donc du coup ces mêmes personnes vont
contaminer d'autres personnes mais en
france on continue de gérer ça en
libérant le plus vite possible pour
alertera au travail
les gens qui sont encore faiblement
contagieux on ne nie sol pas les
patients contacts qui sont sous le même
toit
donc tout ça c'est une vous remettez ça
avec des fêtes de noël c'est une
explosion qui va arriver donc lui il
faut durcir les allemands l'ont compris
ils ont calé leurs modèles épidémique
dessus et vous verrez aujourd'hui on
pleure sur les allemands et demain on va
encore regarder on dira 8 mai français
avait choisi la mauvaise stratégie mais
c'est enfin c'est juste évident les
objectifs des français c'est 5000 cas
par jour
atteint les projections sont plutôt sur
dix huit mille ça doit nous empêcher de
les confiner pour noël françois cocq en
tout cas on voit et ça vient d'être dit
qu'il aurait fallu atteindre des
objectifs beaucoup plus bas que ce que
nous nous apprêtons à atteindre dans
l'est dans les jours qui viennent
preuve que le deuxième des confinement
est déjà un échec et ce qui risque
d'être un échec si on voit l'apathie qui
est celle du gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement la gestion des fêtes
de fin d'année parce qu'il va y avoir
des premières réunions de famille au
moment de noël et une semaine après une
forte les gens auront été contaminées
ils vont pouvoir dispersé encore le
virus pour la grande fiesta comme ça
vient d'être dit du du jour de l'an donc
la question est qu'est-ce qu'on met en
place vous venez de passer un sujet sur
ce qui est fait en allemagne je viens
d'entendre et ça me semble le bon sens
par exemple que quoi qu'en dise le
ministre jean michel blanquer en les
élèves peuvent et les enfants peuvent
être vecteurs ils sont pas forcément
gravement malade ils peuvent être
vecteurs de la transmission du virus
que font les allemands ils font des
vacances à rallonge au moment des fêtes
de fin d'année de manière à ce que en
amont et en aval les enfants et puis
leurs parents et donc les foyers
puissent être sain c'est à dire qui est
pas de contamination que qui ait pas de
cas positifs avérée est-ce que ça serait
pas de bon ton par exemple de mettre sur
la table l'idée que les vacances
scolaires pourrait être avancée de 48
heures pour laisser par exemple une
semaine avant le réveillon de noël
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas envisager
les tests en amont des réveillons et au
lendemain des réveillons que nous
propose le gouvernement a rien
aujourd'hui on a un constat où les
ministres se succèdent et le président
s'en vient nous dire que c'est la faute
des températures que c'est une vague qui
frappe toute l'europe et que finalement
eux n'y sont pour rien ces gens se sont
auto administré un virus d'immunité
politique et de responsabilité politique
il me sens responsable de rien et ça
pose un problème parce qu'au contraire
il devrait agir merci en tout cas à tous
les trois on arrive déjà bout de notre
débat merci à laurent alexandre merci à
bertrand legrand et
vous-même françois cocq d'avoir été avec
nous alors que donald trump annonce à
l'instant un décret pour prioriser la
livraison de vaccins aux états unis
avant les autres pays
merci à tous les trois dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous
reviendrons sur la visite d' emmanuel
macron au creusot afin de montrer son
soutien sa filiale filière nucléaire une
nous parlerons avec alexis poule a de
cela dans son édito nom reviendra
ensuite sur les ventes d'armes exécutif
qui ne voient pas d'un bon oeil à un
contrôle plus strict et démocratique de
ses exportations
[Musique]
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image de bad une icône absolue d'un dieu
vivant parce que il a porté très haut
les couleurs d'un pays qui était
humiliée par la guerre des malouines ce
pays a gagné la coupe du monde alors
c'est pas une victoire militaire mais
c'est une revanche politique des
sportifs sur une défaite militaire parce
que la politique et le sport font
finalement bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique il c'était un homme
d'ultragauche on connaît sa proximité
avec castro on connaît sa proximité avec
hugo chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs d'y incarner la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central
vous êtes encore en train de dire
finalement diego maradona c'est l'homme
du passé ce cap a un côté paradoxal le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que le
personnage n'est pas lisse équitable
type aspérités et c'est pour ça que
c'est un personnage de légende
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense on est tout au long des années
l'alliance atlantique s'est investi dans
des guerres qui n'étaient pas toujours
réellement en ligne avec ses objectifs
stack
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet 10 juillet les mots n'assure
contre la grèce et la présence de dieu à
dist syriens venus d'idlib haut karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne que c'est
à l'europe d'être en capacité d'assumer
la responsabilité de sa propre sécurité
et d'agir de manière autonome quand
c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu des
divergences avec l europe pourront nous
le faire
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez une visite
aujourd'hui d' emmanuel macron sur le
site industriel du groupe framatome du
creusot en saône et loire
un déplacement pour défendre la filière
nucléaire civil et militaire
accompagné des ministres de la
transition écologique de l'économie et
des armées le chef de l'état est allé à
la rencontre des représentants des
acteurs du secteur tels que edf aura nos
ou encore navale groupe ainsi que de
leurs salariés
le président qui misent sur le nucléaire
en matière énergétique et écologique
écouter notre avenir énergétique et
écologique passe par le nucléaire
pourvu que l'on progresse sur la gestion
des déchets sur la sûreté et je vous
sais là aussi pleinement mobilisé
l'énergie nucléaire est une énergie
décarbonée une énergie sûre et pour en
parler nous sommes avec alexis poulain
c'est notre rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir lexie merci alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
le soutien au nucléaire quels sont les
vrais enjeux d enjeu de souveraineté
économique écologique mais aussi en
matière de défense puisque il a dévoilé
également le futur porte-avions
nucléaire qui sait la propulsion
nucléaire le temps qu'un porte avions de
nouvelle génération
la france est le seul pays avec les
états unis à avoir ce type d'engin un
porte-avions à propulsion nucléaire donc
deux moteurs nucléaire c'est était
extrêmement important pour le montrer
mais en terme de souveraineté de et de
défense il ya un bémol tout de même
puisque certaines pièces de ce porte
avions vont être importée des états unis
notamment et il y à il ya déjà eu un
précédent lors de la guerre d'irak quand
jacques chirac avait refusé de
participer
les etats unis ont une arme qui leur
permet d'interdire d'empêcher l'export
d'armes américaines qui s'appelle
l'international trafic in arms
regulations est là pour ce nouveau
porte-avions et bien on aura toujours
des pièces nécessaires notamment pour
les catapultes et pour les systèmes de
drones embarquez donc ça limite tout à
fait la force de projection française
même si la filière nucléaire est poussé
par par emmanuel macron oui alors un
soutien au nucléaire est la défense en
pleine semaine consacrée à l'écologie et
l'économie décarbonée
c'est le en même temps cher au président
oui c'est un en même temps qui ne
satisfait personne ni les écologistes
vieille génération qui ont toujours
milité contre le nucléaire ni les pro
nucléaires qui se disent finalement si
cette filière nucléaire est si
importante pourquoi vouloir limiter le
poids du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique français
il faut rappeler que la france a un des
plus grand parc nucléaire au monde en
terme de population il s'agit de 58
réacteurs que nous avons là nous avons
besoin aussi d'approvisionnement à
l'étranger hors anokye sécurisé
l'approvisionnement de la filière de
l'uranium
naturel 8000 à 9000 tonnes que nous
devons importer chaque année pour un
coût entre 500 millions et 1 milliard
d'euros donc c'est un combustible bon
marché mais la demande devrait augmenter
dans les années qui viennent de 20 à 30%
pour la décennie 2030 2040 et est
toujours évidemment cette question
pourquoi alors réduire le nucléaire il a
été d'ailleurs très précautionneux
emmanuel macron en parlant des réacteurs
nouvelle génération le p r qui a pris
beaucoup de retard avec des défauts
notamment dans la fabrique des cuves
suite à la reprise des usines à au
creusot notamment et donc il a dit
attendre 2023 pour voir s'il y aura un
plan de développement de nouvelles
centrales et comment tout ça va se
passer aujourd'hui on voit bien
effectivement les avantages du nucléaire
c'est d'être une énergie propre sur le
carbone mais qui pose problème quant au
traitement des déchets puisque
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de solution
technique pour la gestion sur des
déchets à par l'enfouissement et à
chaque fois qu'on choisit un site
d'enfouissement et bien il ya toujours
un problème avec les populations locales
et on peut on peut les comprendre
donc voilà un peu toutes les questions
et puis la question posée la fermeture
de fessenheim avoir des objectifs assez
court pour fermiers différentes
centrales
quel est l'intérêt si le mix10
finalement du renouvelable ne permet pas
d'arriver à hauteur et si nous devons
importer de l'énergie d'allemagne par
exemple qui elle fait tourner des
centrales à charbon
donc encore une fois quelques l envi
politique au delà des annonces
électoralistes et quelle stratégie
réelle pour le mix énergétique français
alors les écolos n'en parle puisqu'il
sont fâchés alexis avec la convention
oui sont très fâchés cette semaine est
consacrée à l'écologie on voit bien dans
le timing choisi par le président il y
aura les ai rendu sur la convention
citoyenne sur le climat et là en
l'occurrence les personnes qui ont
participé à cette convention citoyenne
sur le climat sont extrêmement déçu de
la façon dont l'exécutif traite
finalement les conclusions on est passé
d'un discours du président qui disait
qu'il allait prendre toutes les mesures
et faire en sorte qu'elles soient
rapidement mises en place par
l'assemblée et que très peu de mesures
finalement ce rémy sur le côté et là en
discussion à la fois sur le projet de
loi de finances actuellement discutée un
tiers des mesures
sont déjà mises à la poubelle et pour le
reste et bien cédé trahison par exemple
sur trahison de la parole présidentielle
à tel point que celui qui portait cette
convention citoyenne pour le climat
cyril dion a lancé une pétition en ligne
pour bien demandé au président de
revenir sur ses engagements et le tenir
à ses engagements mais on voit bien que
finalement cette convention citoyenne
pour le climat a été un outil de
communication comme l'a été le grand
débat lors de la campagne des
présidentielles
et comme risque de l'être également le
beauvau de la sécurité a annoncé
aujourd'hui en janvier pour les forces
de police et la sécurité donc c'est
toute la limite de cet exercice du en
même temps de cette pseudo démocratie
participative qui sert d'abord à la
communication présidentielle est très
peu finalement à la décision collective
et le veau de la sécurité dont on
parlera allègrement à 21h merci beaucoup
alexis poulain pour votre édito rien en
vie dans ce rapport parlementaire qui
pourrait bien créer la panique dans les
rangs de l'exécutif est gêné les petites
affaires de matignon au coeur de ce
travail parlementaire l'idée d'un
contrôle plus strict des exportations
d'armements made in france
un rapport qui relance le débat sur le
rôle de l'hexagone en zone de guerre
tels que la libye ou le yémen mais c'est
mme shelly préserver ses intérêts
chouchoutez des clients qui participent
directement ou pas à de nombreux
conflits de par le monde en matière de
vente d'armes la position du
gouvernement français est clair quitte à
déclarer la guerre à des membres du
parlement
parmi eux deux députés jacques maire de
la république en marche et michèle
tabarot du groupe l'est républicain
à l'origine de cette panique au coeur de
l'exécutif un rapport parlementaire sur
un contrôle plus strict et démocratique
des exportations d'armements en d'autres
termes à qui sont destinés les armes
fabriquées par la france et surtout à
quelle fin parmi les 35 propositions du
rapport une inédite la création d'une
commission parlementaire chargée de
contrôler les exportations d'armements
une proposition très vite torpillée par
les services de matignon sentant la
menace se préciser selon une note du
secrétariat général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale la sg
dsn organisme indépendant des services
du premier ministre une telle
proposition porterait atteinte aux
intérêts et aux engagements de la france
sous couvert d'un objectif d'une plus
grande transparence et d'un meilleur
dialogue entre les pouvoirs exécutif et
législatif
l'objectif sont bien deux contre un de
la politique du gouvernement en matière
d'exportations en renforçant le contrôle
parlementaire
un tel contrôle de l'action de
l'exécutif risquerait de nuire à la
crédibilité des engagements de la france
et à sa capacité à exporter une note de
quatre pages classé confidentiel défense
détaillé par nos confrères de disque
love où l'exécutif tente tant bien que
mal de justifier sa politique jouant
tantôt la carte du secret défense tantôt
celle des intérêts nationaux
en d'autres termes étouffer cette libye
parlementaire visant à exiger une trop
grande transparence sur les ventes
d'armes en avril 2019 le mediadisk laws
avait déjà pointé du doigt les
agissements de la france en matière de
vente d'armes notamment dans le cadre du
conflit au yémen qui a fait au bas mot
plus de cent mille morts depuis 2014
deux de nos confrères publié une enquête
intitulée made in france
ou comment la france participe
indirectement à la guerre au yémen en
vendant ses armes à l'arabie saoudite et
aux émirats arabes unis une enquête
gênante qui avait valu aux deux
journalistes de disclose geoffrey niveau
sli et mathias des stalles à l'origine
de ces révélations
un petit passage par la case bureaux de
la direction générale du renseignement
intérieur c'était le 14 mai 2010 neuf
dans le cadre d'une enquête préliminaire
pour je cite compromission du secret de
la défense nationale
car c'est bien là la question suivante
qui est au coeur de toutes ces
préoccupations où la france participe
elle ne serait ce qu'un directement à
des crimes de guerre commis en libye ou
encore au yémen
rien que pour le yémen l'état français a
livré pour 1,3 milliard d'euros
d'armement en arabie saoudite un acteur
majeur de ce conflit
le ministère des armées assure pourtant
que les armes vendues leçon à des fins
défensives
nous n'avons jamais prétendu qu'aucune
arme française n'était utilisée au yémen
mais nous n'avons aujourd'hui aucune
preuve qui attesterait que des armes de
fabrication français sont utilisés
à dessein contre des populations civiles
en mars dernier un classement de
l'institut sipri établissait que la
france était le troisième plus gros
exportateur d'armes au monde avec plus
de 7% de part de marché rien qu'en 2018
elle avait vendu pour 9,1 milliards
d'euros d'armement un marché juteux qui
semble préférable de protéger quitte à
détourner le regard sur l' usage des
armes et protéger l'anonymat des riches
et puissants clients de l'hexagone car
cette volonté de plus grande
transparence sur l'identité des
acheteurs du rapport parlementaire
l'exécutif souhaite la voir disparaître
entre les considérations éthiques de la
protection d'un marché très rémunérateur
matignon semble avoir choisi son camp
quitte à ce que les vélleités de
démocratie du parlement en la matière
elle ne fasse pas long feu
et pour en parler nous sommes
précisément avec geoffrey livolsi
cofondateur de disclose bonsoir geoffrey
lee volcy merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors vous aimez
vivre dangereusement puisque comme beth
chemise nous le disaient vous aviez fait
un petit passage par le bureau des
renseignements intérieurs et là vous
êtes de nouveau en pointe sur ce dossier
désarmement vous persistez vous signez
l'euro persiste parce qu'on reçoit des
informations et ces médias qui enquête
sur les faits et les faits sont qu'on a
reçu notre confidentiel défense issu
d'un des services du gouvernement et qui
étayent la la la la volonté la stratégie
du gouvernement sur ce sujet de contrôle
des exportations d'armes
alors cette note gouvernementale vous la
connaissez une personne puisque vous en
révéler le contenu
les préconisations sont sont claires
peut-on vraiment attendre des décisions
dans les semaines à venir
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il ya vraiment
une volonté du gouvernement à travers
cette note de préparer la réplique à ce
rapport qui première en france qui a
amené une volonté du parlement de se
saisir des questions des ventes d'armes
et de leur contrôle
et c'est un contrôle qui est effectif
dans de nombreux pays européens
notamment en angleterre où les
parlementaires ont leur mot à dire sur
les ventes d'armes de leur pays et en
france on sent bien que l'exécutif à
travers ses notes prépare sa réplique
qui est de dire non définitif à toute
volonté du parlement de s'ingérer dans
ces sujets alors c'est vrai vous avez
cité l'angleterre mais c'est vrai aussi
pour l'allemagne c'est vrai aussi plus
loin pour les états unis où le congrès
veille au grain en ce domaine
que peut dire que sont les arguments
proposait justement par le gouvernement
français pour se soustraire à ce
contrôle
l'un des arguments principaux qui est
avancé par l'exécutif c'est le risque
pour les exportations notamment à des
clients 10 ans
bhl qui peuvent être l'arabie saudite
mais qui sont aussi l'egypte et de
soumettre la l'exportation des armes
françaises à des questions politiques
c'est-à-dire doit-on exporté à des
régimes qui utilisent ces armes contre
les civils au goût contre leur propre
population ce quelqu'un en egypte où les
1 française avait notamment servi à la
répression des manifestations et
l'exécutif ne veut pas du tout que cette
question soit soumise au débat
démocratique
est ce que cela peut vraiment justement
nuire à la crédibilité des engagements
de la france et sa capacité à exporter
alors c'est sûr que en soumettant le
contrôle des exportations à des
questions liées au respect des droits de
l'homme liées au fait qu'on n'utilise
pas ses armes contre les crimes de
guerre on se retrouve a pu exporter à
certains pays c'est des décisions
compris certains états européens
l'allemagne par exemple a fait le choix
depuis plus de un an de ne plus exporter
d'armes vers l'arabie saoudite
si on comprend bien on a envie plutôt en
france de préserver l'opinion publique
la communication de préserver l'opinion
publique en fait le débat sur les ventes
d'armes c'est un débat qui apparaît
récemment suite aux révélations il ya un
an de 10 clauses notamment qui était
encore jusqu'à très peu de temps fait
tant débat qui n'en était pas un au sein
de la société française et ça le devient
et donc ça gêne le gouvernement parce
que jusqu'à présent il n'y avait pas
vraiment de volonté de contrôle renforcé
des exportations est maintenant le
parlement lui-même et les propres
députés de la majorité se saisisse de
ces propositions
c'est aussi une manne financière
évidemment éminemment importante la
france troisième exportateur d'armes à
l'avant du 1 pour exemple près de 9,1
milliards d'euros d'armes en 2018
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a les moyens
effectivement on peut se poser la
question de se priver de cette manne
financière
alors ça c'est pas à nous de le dire il
ya des experts qui vous diront que c'est
en fait par les commandes en saison
pourrait suffisamment
soutenir on va dire l'économie du
complexe industriel aux militaires mais
effectivement derrière il ya des lobbys
qui sont ces grandes entreprises
ces grands vendeurs d'armes qui ont
attiré à ce que la france ne met pas
trop de barrières à ce commerce
merci en tout cas geoffrey livolsi
cofondateur du site d'investigation
disclose qui a publié donc cette note
gouvernementale merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt france on le
reste de l'actualité en france près de
six ans après l'ondé de choc à des
attentats de janvier 2015 le parquet
antiterroriste réclame de lourdes peines
contre la plupart des 14 accusés
ils sont jugés devant la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris le point avec notre
reporter katia technique
c'est un réquisitoire exemplaire les
avocats généraux ont estimé que la
plupart des accusés avaient connaissance
des intentions terroristes dames et 10
coulibaly alors sans surprise la
perpétuité a été requise contre le
principal accusé ali riza paulette pour
les autres de 5 à 7 ans ont été requis à
l'encontre des prévenus contre lesquels
les chefs d'association de malfaiteurs
terroristes ont été abandonnées de 13 à
20 ans ont été requis pour les proches
de mehdi coulibaly et de 15 à 18 ans
pour les trafiquants d'armes présumé
même s'il connaissait pour certains à
peine à mehdi coulibaly un réquisitoire
jugée sévère par la défense qui pensent
que leur client ne sont que des seconds
couteaux jeu proposait d'écouter
l'avocat de médecine carassou l'art un
garagiste belge qui a vendu une voiture
pour amedi coulibaly et possiblement des
armes
je suis effectivement très surpris par
la sévérité des réquisitions
je le disais tout à l'heure en une
demi-heure
le parquet a demandé plus de deux
siècles de prison plus de deux siècles
et tout le monde est surpris par la
sévérité parce que s'il y en a qui
méritent des peines un peu plus haute
d'autres méritent d'avoir des peines
plus basse et notamment mon client
monsieur carasso l'art qui manifestement
n'a jamais mis les pieds en france qui a
été impliqué dans cette affaire pour
vendre une voiture alors que c'est
on est venu chez lui pour qu'il donne de
l'argent alors qu que c'est même pas lui
qui a vendu la voiture c'est monsieur
stassi qu'il a vendu en grèce et qui n'a
même pas été impliqué dans la sphère et
lui il se retrouve avec quinze ans ce
c'est incompréhensible
les avocats du principal accusé ali reza
paulette ou plaidé cet après midi pour
mettre coûtant peyre on ne sait par
exemple pas occupée des principaux
fournisseurs d'armes en effet mehdi
coulibaly a utilisé des armes qui
provenait d'une filière lilloise elle
était gérée par un identitaire français
également indiqué or celui ci a bien été
jugé mais dans le cadre d'une autre
affaire à lille il a été condamné à une
faible peine pour cela cela a de quoi
étonner dans la mesure où les autres
fournisseurs d'armes se retrouve bien
dans ce procès là autres arguments
développés par la défense si ali
paulette avait connu les intentions des
médicaux les valley pourquoi n'est-il
pas partie tout comme hayat boumédiène
ou encore les frères belhoucine quelques
jours avant les attentats
voilà des arguments développés par la
défense pour tenter d'infléchir la cour
un restaurant mcdonald's converti en
plate forme d' aide alimentaire depuis
le premier confinement le lieu situé
dans les quartiers nord de marseille
connaît un second souffle et de mulhouse
est essentielle aux besoins de la
population locale
un sujet d'isabelle ferrières et grâce
d'ailleurs on est parti l'essentiel de
ce panier garni aidera probablement une
famille dans le besoin
une chaîne de l'espoir organisées par
les bénévoles du mcdo solidaire situé à
saint barthélémy dans les quartiers nord
de marseille
c'est lors du premier confinement que
ces textes établissement de restauration
rapide a été réquisitionnée en urgence
plus de 3500 colis alimentaires y
étaient distribués chaque semaine on a
essayé de s'auto-organiser pendant le
premier confinement et on a réussi à
créer
machine de guerre qui a été mis en place
pour la solidarité et l'intelligence
collective
au lieu de sortir des hamburgers on sort
d huile riz les pâtes tout ce que ces
personnes là ont besoin
alarmés par la situation des bénévoles
de tout milieu social viennent prêter
main forte à l'occasion de ce deuxième
confinement aujourd'hui c'est pauline
étudiante qui est venu apporter son
soutien sam sur un coeur chez en année
de césure donc forcément j'ai envie de
travailler
je suis venu plusieurs fois et une fois
c'était que des femmes ont parfois des
papas qui ne récupérez des couches lait
pour les bébés et on voit que c'est très
très compliqué pour eux de venir déjà
ici parce que c'est quelque part c'est
honteux pour eux alors que mon vrai nom
une misère honteuse pour certains
assumée par d'autres mari retraité a
longtemps aider les plus nécessiteux
aujourd'hui c'est à son tour d'accepter
cette main tendue
quand je travaillais j'ai fait beaucoup
de bénévolat au secours populaire
et malheureusement c'est moi maintenant
que je me retrouve mais j'ai pas honte r
ma situation c'est que je suis dans le
besoin j'ai une petite retraite
heureusement la paix à des associations
comme ici la population à aider et
diverses des retraités des étudiants
mais aussi des personnes en situation
irrégulière qui vivent habituellement de
travail informel des activités qui
malheureusement sont à l'arrêt depuis le
premier confinement pour marier comme je
travaille pas on a besoin de faire la
course avant le travail de noir qu'on me
l'a pas le papier et maintenant comme il
ya le corona il travaille tu le méritais
mieux quand je lis le journal
je vois que tout le monde est en
difficulté et moi alors qu'il ne possède
absolument rien c'est donc normal que je
sois très inquiète
une demande en constante augmentation
dans ce lieu emblématique qui avait été
l'épicentre d'un long conflit social
jusqu'à sa liquidation judiciaire le 12
décembre 2019
aujourd'hui kamel l'un des syndicalistes
phare à l'initiative de la plateforme
souhaite transformer le restaurant
solidaire en sic une société coopérative
d'intérêt collectif pour créer de
l'emploi et accroître l'aide alimentaire
1 le meilleur moyen pour combattre la
délinquance la prostitution et le
radicalisme c'est que par le travail et
aujourd'hui si nous avons des voyous low
cost dans nos quartiers et la
prostitution et ces jeunes qui sont en
perdition
c'est parce qu'on n'entend pas là mais
pour le moment la structure se développe
n'étant pas reconnue par la préfecture
elle et bénéficient donc d'aucune aide
de la part de la banque alimentaire mais
uniquement de dons d'associations ou de
commerces locaux
un soutien qui n'est pas de trop alors
que la pandémie se poursuit et que
l'hiver n'a pas encore débuté dans
quelques instants rester avec nous nous
évoquons la tenue à partir du mois de
janvier d'un beauvau de la sécurité sur
une réforme de la police dans un
contexte où les images de violences
policières se multiplient et puis nous
parlerons de la candidature de la
présidentielle 2022 de jacqueline
gourault ex figure d gilet jaune
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça
cette réduction du débat justement entre
le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat bhl de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que s'il est une histoire de vie
et de mort
il faut protéger la végétation faut
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
santé
tout ça c'est lié n'oublions pas que
tous nos problèmes viennent du mépris
qu'on a sur le reste du monde vivant
donc il faut il faut arrêter de laisser
les chasseurs faire leur bêtise et je
suis poli
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu valable c'est fini pour moi est
ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la
radicalisation mais c'est la
radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
ep
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense en europe et tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs tactiques
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début d' attaques contre la frégate
courbet était juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de thua
d'ist syriens venus dit libre haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne de 7 à
l'europe d'être en capacité d'assumer la
responsabilité de sa propre sécurité et
d'agir de manière autonome quand c'est
nécessaire mais compte tenu des
divergences avec l europe pourront nous
le faire
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film à
projets un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature
ça reste un art déco maintenant c'est
l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques
c'était godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma on
lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la dent fip et brûle c'est
à dire le rapport entre la population et
territoire qui est porteur de causalité
d'explications mais des densités un
grain aujourd'hui appartement il ya des
chaînes de comptes avion du retour à
l'intérieur vraisemblablement du milieu
familial parce qu'on a des familles qui
vivent à trois générations et c'est tout
cet ensemble de causes qui
constitutionnellement un syndrome en
quelque sorte social et dont le colis
est à la fois le révélateur est
malheureusement la cause déterminante
ponctuelles je suis très frappé entre
eux présentant des sciences sociales par
finalement le progrès considérables
comme apple dans cette pandémie qu'avant
dérivation n'a pas que des mauvais côtés
en un an on a mis au point pratiquement
avec
[Musique]
et
un bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure française tout de suite
voici des titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 8 décembre
emmanuel macron annonce un beauvau de la
sécurité objectif apaiser des esprits à
perdre après l affaire est clair
notamment qui a renforcé la polémique
sur les violences policières
mais également pour accélérer la
transformation de la police
une proposition loin de satisfaire
l'opposition avant le vote du collège
électoral lundi prochain tous les états
américains doivent certifier ce mardi à
leurs résultats électoraux il ne sera
alors plus possible de les contester
première étape de l'officialisation de
la victoire de joe biden donald trump
lui vient d'annoncer un décret pour
prioriser la livraison de vaccins aux
états unis avant d autres pays en
république démocratique du congo la
police est déployée au sein du parlement
à kinshasa on croit une bataille que se
livrent les partisans du président félix
tshisekedi et ceux de la majorité
parlementaire fidèle à son prédécesseur
joseph kabila des violences qui font
suite à la demande du président de la
fin de la coalition au pouvoir qu'ils
formaient depuis janvier 2019 avec la
majorité parlementaire et pro kabila
[Musique]
emmanuel macron annonce donc un beauvau
de la sécurité objectif apaiser les
esprits après laffaire michel éclair qui
a renforcé la polémique sur les
violences policières
mais également pour accélérer la
transformation de la police les
explications avec david khalifa remettre
les choses à plat pour éviter ce genre
de scène
voilà l'objectif premier de ce nouveau
de la sécurité en pleine polémique sur
les violences policières
emmanuel macron veut drastiquement
changé les choses afin d'améliorer les
conditions d'exercice des forces de
l'ordre et consolider leurs liens avec
les français une idée loin de satisfaire
l'opposition
moi j'aimerais bien que le président de
la république enfin en matière de
sécurité
une idée claire de la façon dont il faut
mobiliser des moyens avoir une vision
pour la sécurité pour la paix pour
protéger les français
et puis une stratégie je vois rien de
tout ça alors on peut appeler ça le
gourou de la sécurité mais si c'est pour
demain lâcher les forces de l'ordre
comme le président de la république le
fait un jour sur deux puis revenir en
arrière puis re proposer quelque chose
tout ça tourne à vide ça fait trois ans
et demi que ça tourne à vide ça fait
trois ans et demi que les français sont
pas protégés moi j'ai j'ai l'impression
qu'à chaque fois que le chef de l'état
devant un problème il a tendance à
inventer un truc un comité théodule
fait surtout pour gagner du temps et
donc en général il ne prend aucun au
plus conséquence des choses qui ont été
proposées dans ces comités 7 est vrai
que le grand débat ça a été vrai avec
eux
le conseil le comité citoyen sur lui
avec les questions d'environnement lui
climatique
et là j'ai un peu peur que ça sur la
même chose le chef de l'état prendra
part personnellement à ce grenelle de la
police qui réunira en janvier des
représentants des forces de l'ordre
des élus et des citoyens une initiative
en réponse aux nombreuses critiques
adressées par les syndicats de police à
la suite de l'interview donnée par
emmanuel macron aux médias brut la
semaine dernière et notamment sur le
contrôle au faciès
malgré mes engagements je suis obligé de
le constater parce qu'on a quand
j'écoute les jeunes ou moins jeunes en
tout cas toutes celles et ceux qui ont
une bonne raison d'être discriminés
parce qu'ils sont maghrébine maghrébins
ou d'origine maghrébine parce qu'ils
sont noirs parce que voilà leur couleur
de peau leur allure le quartier fait que
tout est prédisposé ils se sentent
discriminés et donc ça commence comme ça
et en effet à ce moment là la haine de
la police commence là et les quelques
chiffres dont on dispose ils disent des
mots qui ont déclenché la colère des
policiers plusieurs actions dont l'arrêt
des contrôles d'identité se sont
déroulées à travers la capitale pour
dénoncer ces propos une interview qui a
laissé des traces au sein des forces de
l'ordre
même si votre discours venait dans sa
globalité souligné l'action des forces
de l'ordre et des policiers mes
collègues retiennent une seule chose à
savoir que les contrôles au faciès
existent qui sont une réalité qu'un
jeune homme de couleur à plus de chances
d'être contrôlés que les autres
personnes cette affirmation est venu
remettre en cause la qualité du travail
quotidien des forces de l'ordre et
particulièrement celui des policiers
nationaux surtout ceux engagés dans les
quartiers difficiles
au centre des discussions de ce beau mot
de la sécurité formation encadrement
moyens captations vidéos des
interventions inspection effectifs et
lien entre la police et population
en clair les sept chantiers annoncés par
le ministre de l'intérieur
par ailleurs 1,5 milliard d'euros de
crédits budgétaires supplémentaires
pourraient être débloqués l'issue de
cette réunion
salué par les syndicats mais insuffisant
pour eux ce type de réunion ne permet
pas de régler les problèmes
le syndicat alliance à deux
ailleurs prévenu qu'il ne répondrait pas
à l'invitation présidentielle et côté
policiers la colère ne retombe pas après
la création d'une plate forme anti
discrimination une centaine d'entre eux
étaient rassemblées en début de soirée
devant le commissariat de créteil est
les précisions de notre reporter nadège
hatteras ac manifestation devant le
siège de la police départementale du
val-de-marne qui se déroulent dans le
calme
un calme en apparence seulement puisque
la colère est réelle au sein des membres
des forces de l'ordre profession qui
souffre depuis de nombreuses années de
conditions de travail difficiles mais ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres d'après de
nombreux policiers ici et bien ce sont
les propos aide emmanuel macron diffusée
sur brut vendredi dernier aux sujets à
des contrôles au faciès et à des
violences policières des propos qui ont
choqué plus d'un au sein des forces de
l'ordre
nous ce qu'on attend du président de la
république c'est d'abord de la
reconnaissance est ce qu on attend
d'ailleurs de la part de la plupart des
élus de la république c'est de la
reconnaissance mais c'est aussi des
actes quand par exemple on demande le
floutage systématique pour les policiers
lorsque l'on demande new alliance police
nationale
qu'il y ait des sanctions qui soit ferme
à l'encontre des violences contre mes
collègues à l'encontre des gens qui
commettent des violences contre mes
collègues c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'on
demande mais aujourd'hui ces actes qui
viennent pas ils viennent pas et en plus
lorsque le président s'exprime c'est
pour clairement
émettre une défiance vis-à-vis des
fonctionnaires de police et ça c'est
juste intolérables on a des numéros
verte pour tout depuis deux trois ans et
c'est bizarre c'est presque le même
numéro vert à chaque fois ça doit être
une plateforme mutualisée et la voix sur
les violences policières
on a déjà on avait accès ali jes une
plateforme internet on a beaucoup de
choses
la police s'est c'est le corps de
l'administration qui est le plus
contrôlé et le plus sanctionné
certainement quand il le faut et à juste
titre mais je crois qu'au niveau mondial
on est pas on n'a pas d'équivalent d'une
police qui fait son travail et de
manière aussi républicaine et l'annoncé
d'un beauvau de la sécurité a été
accueillie ici avec beaucoup de
scepticisme alliance et synergie deux
des plus gros syndicats de police sont
d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà fait savoir
qu'ils ne participeront pas à ce
grenelle de la police ce qu'attendent
les manifestants et si les forces de
l'ordre se sont elles des engagements
fermes plus que de belles paroles de la
part du président de la république un
bobo de la sécurité à l'image du grand
débat ou de la convention citoyenne sur
le climat est ce une opération de
communication électorale emmanuel macron
se sert-il des policiers en fin stratège
politique
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
david olivier reverdy secrétaire
national adjoint du syndicat alliance
police bonsoir david olivier reverdy
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
antoine hull et oman responsable de la
communication numérique de la france
insoumise bonsoir à vous aussi antoine
aller au mans merci d'être là alors
après les propos d' emmanuel macron
reconnaissant l'existence des contrôles
au faciès en réponse deux syndicats de
police dont le vôtre un david olivier
reverdy alliance 1 ont appelé à ne plus
faire de contrôle réponse de l'exécutif
un bobo de la sécurité en janvier pour
fixer une réforme ça répond à vos
attentes où vous vous sentez lâché par
le président david olivier reverdy
non mais en fait jérôme et l'annoncent
de du président d'aujourd'hui si on la
remet dans le contexte
permettez-nous de douter de sa
s'inquiètent de sa sincérité
quelques jours après des annonces
fracassantes contre la police dans le
média brut pensant faire plaisir à une
jeunesse à laquelle il s'adressait
il a en fait fustiger la police
nationale il a fustigé les cent
cinquante mille fonctionnaires de police
les cent mille gendarmes qui composent
ce pays donc il nous a fusillé sur place
pour faire plaisir il a fait du en même
temps il a voulu faire plaisir aux
jeunes en même temps faire la police au
final il a fait plaisir à personne
il a fait du ni l'un ni l'autre et ce ni
l'un ni l'autre aujourd'hui fait que les
policiers sont dans la rue partout sur
le territoire pas seulement dans le 94
comme votre reporter l'a montré mais
également en province dans toutes les
villes de france
il y aura des actions willy a déjà des
actions qui sont entamées à l'initiative
du syndicat alliance police nationale
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut accepter
des propos d'un président de la
république qui est censé être au dessus
de la mêlée qui est censé prendre de la
hauteur et aujourd'hui il s'est comporté
comme un un vaste citoyens engagés
et il a oublié qu'il était président de
la république alors on va ré écouter
dans cette petite phrase emmanuel macron
qui a mis le feu aux poudres
commentaires faits par le président on
le rappelle lors de son interview aux
médias brut la semaine dernière
aujourd'hui quand on a une couleur de
peau qui n'est pas blanche on est
beaucoup plus contrôlés on est identifié
comme un facteur de problème et c'est
insoutenable
le président qui reconnaît donc certains
contrôles d'identité ne sont pas
toujours légitimes en quelque sorte ça
va dans votre sens
vous à la france insoumise antoine aller
au mans écoutez c'est pas une question
de le reconnaître c'est une question
sont des faits il ya en a en moyenne 20
fois plus de chances de se faire
contrôler dans ce pays quand on est noir
ou arabe
donc c'est un fait établi par ailleurs
c'est inefficace du point de vue concret
puisque ça a été mis en place le
récépissé de contrôle d'identité que
nous demandons et pour lequel nous avons
d'ailleurs déposé une proposition de loi
ça a été mis en place dans une ville
d'espagne et on constate son efficacité
puisque les contrôles inutiles ont
baissé de 75% et les contrôles qui mène
effectivement un contrôle d'un délit ou
d'un problème qui est posé augmente en
réalité de france ont multiplié par
quatre
donc premièrement c'est un problème qui
est clairement constaté dans le pays et
par énormément de gens et en particulier
si vous si vous si vous avez vu les les
reportages qui a été fait aujourd'hui
sur justement les actions qui sont
menées par alliance police mais par
aussi d'autres syndicats de police sur
ces contrôles au faciès qui demande aux
gens est ce que c'est un problème que
vous constatez les gens répondent oui
donc au bout d'un moment monsieur on
peut dire enfin vous pouvez dire ce que
vous voulez mais clairement c'est un
problème que les gens constatent vivent
effectivement ils ne vivent pas quand
ils sont blancs puisque les contrôles au
faciès ça n'arrive pas quand on est
blanc mais c'est un problème qui est
constaté et ça pose un problème
extrêmement grave pour notre pays
puisque la république et doit envoyer le
message et notamment les gens qui ont
l'uniforme avec le drapeau tricolore sur
les pôles doivent envoyer un message qui
est celui de l'égalité entre les
citoyens là ce n'est pas ce que vivent
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes et
ça pose un problème
majeur à mon avis dans notre pays donc
je pense qu'on devrait pouvoir trouver
un moyen de le faire il est assez simple
c'est la mise en place du récépissé de
contrôle d'identité c'est ainsi un moyen
extrêmement simple ça réglerait le
problème et j'ai vraiment du mal à
comprendre pourquoi votre syndicat
s'oppose à la mise en place de cette
mesure à david olivier reverdy pour la
réponse alors deux choses la premier
fait c'est que c'est vrai il ya une
chose qui est établie c'est que la
france a soumise par l'intermédiaire de
monsieur mélenchon on se caractérise par
son anti flics aujourd'hui qui concerne
la police et monsieur mélenchon a pu le
répéter des nombreuses reprises devant
les caméras et de partout où il peut ce
weel peut s'exprimer il l'a encore fait
ses mots à l'encontre du syndicat
alliance police nationale
donc c'est l'anti flic primaire de
monsieur mélenchon s'est battu jusqu'au
bout
c'est vrai que jouer seul devant le
siège de la firme va bien chanter
n'importe c j'invite ce monsieur présent
sur le plein sur sur le direct avec moi
a constaté les plaintes les plaines des
victimes lorsque des victimes font des
fautes déposent des plaintes et
signalent des signalements sur les
individus auteurs des plaintes
vous prenez ces plaintes là et après
vous travaillez avec donc sachez qu'une
chose monsieur sait que l'a proclamé
ouattara sa délinquance à la première
c'est celle des pictes la police la
délinquance est celle que les victimes
les géniales et qu'aujourd'hui la
parodie ce monsieur n'à police m'a
choisi croise et de l'intense lorsque
nous faisait marrer c'est moi filière et
la police confirmant sa délinquance
lorsque la police doit faire des
contrôles d'identité dans certains
quartiers où la mixité sociale n'existe
pas et où l'a dit les difficultés sont
ceux de ces quartiers là la police y
rentrer effet ces contrôles et bien
évidemment c'est facile de nous taxer de
racisme donc je trouve avec des
allégations extrêmement dangereux et
républicaine dans ce pays antoine et au
mans pour la réponse a essayé de parler
en même temps sinon on va pas vous
comprendre déjà qu'on est sur skype
merci le commune
je suis je suis d'accord mais enfin bon
quand quand mon interlocuteur parlant
continuer à raconter un certain nombre
de mentions je veux y revenir
nous n'avons jamais été anti fiq et
d'ailleurs j'en veux pour preuve que
nous sommes
le mouvement qui a déposé qui a demandé
à ce que soit déposé une commission d'
enquête sur les suicides de policiers
parce que nous savons que c'est
difficile le métier de policier et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi votre syndicat ne
l'a pas soutenu par ailleurs vous dites
que la france insoumise serais content
le syndicat alliance mais c'est votre
syndicat monsieur qui est venu
manifester devant le siège de qui
appelaient à manifester devant le siège
de la france en ce propos des jeux
melonchon vie mais parce que et deux et
la numéro n'y ait pas monsieur mélenchon
tient des propos si vous les assumez pas
de les assumer pas ce grenier jeannois
n'y a pas je ne renie absolument pas les
propos de jean-luc mélenchon s'étaient
sur la question des barbares du
comportement barbare et depuis nous
avons été rejoints par un certain nombre
de personnes que vous aurez pris vu de
chez moi
construit d'organisations
internationales mais forcément monsieur
parce que quand un policier menace un
parlementaire et ne respecte pas un
parlementaire alors que le parlementaire
si autre objection la police mais
monsieur vous n'êtes pas au dessus des
lois monsieur et quentin parlementaire
tu donnes mais un parlementaire alors je
vais vous apprendre quelque chose mais
un parlementaire a le droit de se rendre
où il veut quand il veut
voilà ça c'est la loi monsieur c'est
vous ne vous ne la connaissez pas c'est
un gros problème que les policiers ne
connaissent pas la loi mais on n'empêche
pas un parlementaire de se rendre
quelque part voilà
mais quand ça vous laisse lire ici ne se
sont pas allés revendus sur la
perquisition de jean luc mélenchon
effectivement sans commission on
l'imaginé antoine aller au mans oui mais
quand un parlementaire veut se rendre
quelque part il y as droit et
particulièrement quand c'est le siège de
son organisation et particulièrement
quand une autre organisation a déjà été
perquisitionnés le matin et qu'on est au
courant du fait des suggestions sur
l'eau ce n'est pas de sujets
effectivement m
non je voudrais je voudrais répondre
acquis à ce qui a été dit nous n'avons
jamais été anti flics nous signalons des
problèmes
et quand on voit l'interpellation par
exemple de monsieur éclair qui s'est
passé récemment secteur s'éloigne de
débats antoine et au moment de ce qu'on
écrit sur le bobo de la sécurité mais
mais je vous en prie alesi effectivement
ce que vous voulez c'est que je m'étais
après après laffaire est claire je vous
la corde alesi s'éloigne pas du départ
monsieur macron à cette technique
systématique qui consiste dès lors qu'il
ya un problème dans notre pays a renvoyé
un nouveau à un ségur un bientôt on aura
un rivoli des riches peut-être mais à
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème il nous
renvoie vers
à un supposé sommet sûr sûr sûr ce qui
va sur ce qui va décider
mais moi je constate que dans notre pays
il ya des gens qui subissent des
contrôles qui sont des contrôles au
faciès
je constate qu'on a des images qui nous
montrent certaines interpellations qui
sont extrêmement violentes comme celle
de monsieur est clair et je rappelle que
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen que vous n'allez pas me dire
que c'est pas la république la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen parce que c'est quand même elle
quand on était à l'origine dit que quand
on interpelle quelqu'un il est présumé
innocent et que tout excès dans son
interpellation doit être durement
sanctionnés par la loi donc dans ce cas
là ce sont les policiers qui ne
respectent pas la déclaration des droits
de l'homme ce sont les policiers qui
doivent être durement sanctionnés par la
loi et par monsieur est clair qu'ils le
sont ses yeux une leçon car vous rendez
vous va revenir à ce bouddha sécurité
aussitôt annoncée par le chef de l'état
aussitôt communiquer sur les réseaux
sociaux regarder le tweet un de votre
patron le patron de la police le
ministre de l'intérieur ce matin gérald
armen le bouvau de la sécurité annoncées
par le président de la république et la
première pierre de la grande loi de
programmation de la sécurité intérieure
tous les forces de l'ordre mérite depuis
longtemps alors gérald darmanin plutôt
dithyrambique un david olivier reverdy
mais à quoi sert un beauvau de la
sécurité finalement on peut se poser la
question alors que le ministère a rendu
il ya quelques semaines un livret blanc
sur la sécurité intérieure comment vous
percevez cette réaction joyeuse la part
de gérald darmanin gérald darmanin est
peut-être obligé d'avoir cette réaction
joyeuses parties il fait partie du
gouvernement de monsieur macron nous en
attendant c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
satisfait par ce bout de la sécurité là
parce que il y vient comme un cheveu sur
la soupe pour essayer de faire oublier
les propos de monsieur macron donc c'est
vrai que nous on espère revenir sur les
problématiques qui sont les autres à
savoir et qu'on puisse créer un
observatoire de la réponse pénale
cet observatoire de la réponse pénale
c'est à savoir les peines encourues
les peines prononcées qu'on puisse
savoir ce qui se passe réellement dans
la justice qu'on puisse protéger les
policiers dans ce pays parce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas protégé
on demande à ce que le droit à notre
droit à l'image de notre droit au
respect de notre vie privée soit aussi
respecter on demande en fait de la
considération qu'on
sidération qu'on n'a pas et qu'on n'a
pas eu et qu'on a plus avec avec
monsieur macron et depuis ses dernières
déclarations dont il ya trois octaves
sujets qui sont sur la place aujourd'hui
qui sont les nôtres depuis longtemps
longtemps parce que la police longtemps
subi une décrépitude lente mais
inexorable et il est très clair
qu'aujourd'hui lancé un beauvau de la
sécurité comme ça au mieux nulle part
pour essayer de nous faire rentrer dans
nos commissariats parce qu'aujourd'hui
je vous le rappelle les policiers sont
dehors
les policiers exercent leur métier avec
minutie pour montrer à la population que
nous sommes dignes d'être respectés et
que les propos de monsieur monsieur
macron ont mis le feu aux poudres d'une
profession qui est déjà vous l'avez
rappelé extrêmement touchée très
durement touchée antoine est allé au
mans le mode la fallen à la fin pour
vous justement emmanuel macron qu'ils
voulaient apaiser un petit peu ces
tensions entre la police et une certaine
partie peut-être de la population à ce
que c'était la bonne idée je pense que
monsieur macron n'y parviendra pas parce
que il a peur des syndicats policiers et
il a peur notamment du syndicat alliance
qui lui met la pression en allant
manifester devant l'elysée de temps en
temps je pense qu'il faut effectivement
refonder la police dans notre pays mais
la refonder en prenant globalement
l'intégralité de ses missions faut
savoir qu'actuellement 56% des activités
sur le terrain des policiers ça consiste
à contrôler des gens qui ont des
boulette de shit donc franchement je
pense qu'aucun policier pas vous
monsieur non plus ne s'est engagé dans
la police pour faire autre chose et ctg
la population ne peut réussir ou russes
mais pour les yeux je suis le monsieur
je suis exactement entre humble je suis
si vous me laissez finir je suis
exactement en train de vous dire que je
pense que la police a mieux à faire que
de contrôler des boulette de shit je
pense qu'on devrait utiliser nos forces
de police
effectivement en renforçant le
renseignement humain pour faire face aux
menaces terroristes notamment mais pas
seulement aussi à la délinquance
financière aux gens qui sont des
délinquants en col blanc qu'on laisse
courir je vais finir je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire une chose
il ya actuellement sept mille policiers
de la bac et y en a que 5 milles qu'ils
font
est ce qu'on appelle la police
judiciaire qui est justement chargé de
faire le reste donc lutte contre le
proxénétisme lutte contre la délinquance
financière etc
moi je pense qu'on est bien au dessus de
la boxe ne faut pas judiciaire monsieur
vous raconter les pontes de quoi dire je
suis en train de vous dire non sucré
passons sur la voie publique ne sont pas
une psychiatre judiciaire vous si vous
écoutiez plutôt que de parler en continu
je suis en train de vous dire que quand
il ya 7000 policiers pour la bac d'un
côté et 5000 de l'autre pour faire des
choses que je considère bien plus utile
que faire du flagrant délit sur des
boulettes de j'y passais l'inscription
des amis louches police judiciaire dans
ce pays ça serait quand même bien plus
utile en attendant unités il sait police
judiciaire
si vous parlez absolument incroyable
vous voyez quand il est content quand on
parle d'agressivité dans la police vous
en êtes une carte non non non toi né au
mans où placez vous avez eu je pense que
vous avez autant parler l'un et l'autre
un serment mais j'avais déjà fait des
mesures intéressantes à proposer je
pense que monsieur net n'est pas là pour
faire des contraventions sur du c'ur du
du confinement
on en est à 255 milles contravention ça
représente 34 millions d'euros qui sont
prises aux poches des français ça sera
l'objet d'un prochain débat en toi or
antoine les au mans avec grand plaisir
merci en tout cas à vous et merci à
david olivier reverdy qui était venu
donc débattre sur le bobo de la sécurité
on ne manquera pas de vous re est invité
pour parler de ces mesures intéressantes
merci à vous antoine et oman merci
jacqueline moreau figurent des gilet
jaune annoncé hier sa candidature à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
elle devient la troisième candidate
officiellement déclarée à se présenter
devant les français
ancien porte parole des gilet jaune elle
dit avoir pris ses distances avec la
violence du mouvement
âgé de 53 ans il souhaite représenter je
cite la france ordinaire celle dont
personne ne se soucie à paris et pour en
parler nous sommes avec la principale
intéressée jacqueline moreau vous êtes
en direct avec notre défense merci
d'être là alors pourquoi annoncer votre
candidature maintenant bonsoir et merci
de me recevoir alors je j'avais
l'intention d'attendre le mois de
janvier pour annoncer ma candidature
mais ce qui a fait déborder le vase ce
sont les propos d' emmanuel macron aux
médias brut
il ya quelques jours les propos
totalement inacceptables
c'est ça qui a vous a décidé oui tout à
fait parce qu'en fait on n'avait pas un
président en interview dans un média on
avait le candidat emmanuel macron donc
j'estime que le candidat emmanuel macron
à le lancer la campagne
donc j à ce moment là j'ai décidé de de
lancer aussi la mienne
qu'est ce qui vous a justement le plus
choqué dans cette interview qui vous a
poussé vous à vous déclarer pour la
présidentielle écoutez ou outre l'état
de la france parce que c'est ça qui me
donne la nausée
honnêtement quand on voit ce qu'ils ont
fait de notre pays depuis quarante ans
entre le saccager le dévasté et emmanuel
macron est en train de le ruiner d'une
part pour pouvoir mieux le diluer dans
une robe dont il se rêve en premier
président d'un gouvernement européen
donc ça c'est pas possible moi je ne
peux pas me résoudre à regarder mon pays
mourir de cette façon sans rien faire
alors vous souhaitez vous gouvernez au
plus près des territoires de vie
de chacun comment ils parvenir
concrètement et bien pour comprendre les
territoires il faut y être dans les
territoires chose que les laits nos
gouvernants actuels et surtout nos
technocrates qui ne sort jamais qu'ils
ne sortent jamais de leur bureau ne faut
pas donc ils sont incapables de
comprendre les conséquences des
décisions qu'ils prennent puisqu'il ne
venaient ils ne sortent pas de leur
citadelle donc actuellement par exemple
avec la gestion du coc vide
moi j'aimerais demander à tous ces
technocrates combien ils ont perdu sur
leur salaire parce que aujourd'hui on a
quand même des petits entrepreneurs et
enfin jusqu'au gros entrepreneurs qui
sont en train de tout perdre et à paris
tout le monde s'en fout on nous applique
une politique exclusivement parisienne
qui n'a rien à voir avec les territoires
alors ça serait pas mal que tous ces
gens qui se prennent pour des élus parce
que faut pas oublier que les techniques
si je peux me permettre il n'y a quand
même eu plus des dents france que dans
d'autres pays
je vous invite à aller aux états unis
pour voir malheureusement le nombre de
personnes dans la rue qui n'en ont tenu
aucun chômage partiel aucune aide je ne
dis pas que c'est l'idéal en france mais
il ya eu peut-être davantage d'être que
dans certains pays
est ce que vous le concéder alors je
suis tout à fait d'accord mais les aides
qu'on a accordé aux entreprises
il va falloir les rembourser ce sont le
pge c'est un prêt que personne ne pourra
rembourser si on ne tombe on nous
empêche de travailler
donc là il va y avoir un très gros
problème au mois de mai mais juin quand
personne ne va pouvoir rembourser
puisque c'est en comble on nous
maintient en confinement
alors qu'on nous fait appliquer des
protocoles de dengue et on nous
maintient quand même en confinement donc
ça veut bien dire qu'ils sont dans les
deux cas incapable d'appliquer d'édicter
des protocoles qui conviennent puisque
il nous confie donc ça veut bien dire
qu'ils confessent leurs propres
compétences
vous annoncez un usage régulier du
référendum c'était
l'une des réquisitions des
revendications pardon des gilet jaune
précisant que premier porteraient sur
les questions de sécurité et
d'immigration pour quelles raisons tout
simplement parce que c'est la première
préoccupation des français
actuellement les français ont besoin
d'être protégés et la france a besoin
d'être protégée donc il faut
obligatoirement ça la question ne se
pose même plus si vous voulez on est
rendu à un stade tellement élevé
d'insécurité en france que la question
ne se pose plus il faut absolument faire
un référendum pour demander aux citoyens
français à tous les citoyens leur avis
ce n'est plus une question qui se décide
dans un bureau à place beauvau à
l'elysée ou à matignon on doit demande
elle demandait l'avis pardon des
citoyens français
alors vous avez indiqué avoir pris vos
distances avec la violence du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune tout en restant
fidèle à la non violence du canal
historique quel est votre lien
aujourd'hui avec ce mouvement
alors écoutez j'ai toujours des liens
avec les gilet jaune du 17 novembre
évidemment et aujourd'hui j'ai été
envahie de messages de soutien et de
personnes qui se proposent de m'aider
dans cette candidature parce que
évidemment c'est une candidature une
candidature de rupture avec le système
administratif et une rupture avec les 40
années qu'on d'échec convient dessus
bien donc je suis déjà extrêmement
étonné d'avoir autant de soutiens mais
en tous les cas je les remercie beaucoup
alors les soutiens c'est une chose il
faut 500 parrainages d'élus est ce que
vous êtes optimiste sur ce point tout à
fait je suis optimiste puisque déjà je
travaille avec des maires donc gg dans
l'équipe j'ai des mers et j'ai déjà des
personnes qui se sont proposé d'aller me
récolter ces fameuses 500 signatures
mais donc nous sommes confiants merci
beaucoup à jacqueline moreau d'avoir été
avec nous candidate donc à la
présidentielle
de 2022 merci à vous reste avec nous
donc quelques instants à direction les
états unis avant le vote du collège
électoral lundi prochain tous les états
américains doivent certifier ce mardi
leurs résultats électoraux première
étape de l'officialisation de la
victoire de joe biden et puis direction
ensuite la démone république
démocratique du congo
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer
si aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture
et puis les espaces naturels c'est grâce
à la chasse grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse est la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une
femme qu'est ce que vous espérez
apporter justement à ce monde de la
chasse si je peux aider avec avec ce que
je fais sur les réseaux sociaux etc
skhira a montré un autre aspect de la
chasse et à donner envie à certaines
personnes de la découvrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 21h30 soyez les bienvenus bienvenue
sur arte france si vous nous rejoignez
direction maintenant les états unis avec
ce qui ressemble à la première étape de
l'officialisation de la victoire de joe
biden aujourd'hui tous les états
américains devront avoir certifié leurs
résultats électoraux ou au moins fermé
la porte à toute nouvelle contestation
pour désigner les grands électeurs qui
se retrouveront lundi pour sceller le
sort du futur locataire de la maison
blanche
l'étau se resserre dons pour donald
trump dernier échec avec la validation
définitive par l'état de géorgie de la
victoire du candidat démocrate
un succès confirmé par l'exécutif local
coup dur pour le président sortant pour
qui cet état du sud-est est cruciale car
la géorgie déterminera le 5 janvier
prochain lors des élections sénatoriales
la couleur du futur sénat en cas de
défaite et de basculement de la chambre
haute du congrès des responsables de ce
potentiel échec sont déjà désignés par
donald trump
brian kerr josh duncan et le secrétaire
bradera fance perger seront seul
responsable de la perte potentielle de
nos deux grands sénateurs de géorgie
david perdre ue et kelly loeffler il
n'appelleront pas une session spéciale
ni ne contrôleront les signatures les
gens sont en colère
les etats unis qui ont annoncé hier de
nouvelles sanctions contre la chine vise
et 14 e au responsable du parlement
chinois pour leur rôle dans l'adoption
de la loi sur la sécurité nationale
controversée à hong kong c'est vice
président du comité permanent du
parlement et les membres de leurs
familles ne pourront plus entrer sur le
territoire américain
or éventuels avoirs aux états unis
seront gelées et l'accès au système
financier américain leur sera bloqué
nouveau tour de vis de l'administration
trump ces derniers mois elle a multiplié
les attaques contre pékin accusé de
concurrence commerciale déloyale vol de
propriété intellectuelle et recourt à
l'espionnage aux états unis et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis
washington avec tristan cabello maître
de conférences en civilisation
américaine à la john hopkins university
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir
tristan cas vidéo merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france 14 haut responsable du
parlement chinois sanctionné donc
l'administration trump et le
président-élu baydan sont d'accord sur
le sujet une fois n'est pas coutume est
ce le signe d'une probable continuité
dans la confrontation avec pékin oui je
crois qu'il n'y aura pas de différence
entre fondamentalement entre les
administrations byden et
d'administration trump dans les rapports
chinois américains il faut dire que de
toute façon les américains ont toujours
été extrêmement protectionnistes c'était
le cadre de la 35 sur la cas de joe
biden et en plus de ça son nouveau
secrétaire son nouveau ministre des
affaires étrangères anthony blinken a
dit très clairement qu'il était en
concentration totale avec la chine alors
la chine qui elle s'indigne parle
d'ingérence et promet des contre mesures
fermes et forte
les rapports sino-américains comment
peuvent-ils évoluer dans ce cas de
figure
alors on a l'impression qu'il ya
vraiment des tensions qui grandissent
chaque jour entre les chinois des
américains
c'est vrai que pai de nantes ronny
week-end remette de l'huile sur le feu
on a l'impression vraiment et rapports
qui se détériore chaque mois chaque jour
et ça va aller en empirant j'ai
l'impression avec cette nouvelle
administration
alors revenons en maintenant à joe biden
et notamment la crise du coronavirus à
le président élu prévient sans action du
congrès les américains subiront un
retard voire un arrêt de la vaccination
une déclaration pour créer un choc
oui alors il ya vraiment deux discours
complètement différent dakota étrange
qui se félicite de l'avancée des vaccins
c'est vrai que les vaccins arrivent très
vite et il nous l'avait dit juste avant
la campagne puis d'un côté un bail dunn
qui est un discours beaucoup plus sombre
on a l'impression sur 7 sur cette
épidémie qui il est vrai de toute façon
fait de plus dans plus de ravages aux
états unis
les cas de co vide on grandit on qu'on
grandit de manière assez exponentielle
durant dès les dernières semaines tout
principalement d'ailleurs à cause de la
fête de thanksgiving qui a augmenté d
infection est donc là on a vraiment deux
manières de voir c'est à dire d'un côté
la positivité donald trump avec donc les
vaccins qui arrivent et qui promettent
une fin de l'épidémie
et puis de l'autre côté un bail donne
qui nous dit qu'on en est encore très
loin et qu'il va avoir vraiment et je
crois que c'était ses mots hier john
winter c'est à dire une univers très
sombre alors à quelques minutes
d'intervalle le président trump sortant
lui ai annoncé qu'ils me prioriser la
livraison des vaccins pour passer avant
les autres pays alors il reste dans son
rôle en donald trump américaine first il
reste très offensive
est ce que c'est une parole de
communication
on est toujours tenté que de tenter de
dire que c'est une parole de
communication donald trump c'est à dire
qu'il ne peut pas de toute façon se
substituer à la vie de la f10 qui n'a
pas encore donné son avis sur ses
vaccins puisque les vaccins des données
ne sont pas encore disponibles avec des
live qui devrait rendre son avis donc
vers la fin décembre
ça voudrait dire que la vaccination
pourrait commencer très tôt en début de
l'année prochaine
maintenant il est vrai que donald trump
finalement avait raison - avant de la
revendre élections le vaccin arrive et
il arrive à grands pas et il est là
vraiment c'est juste une question de
semaines pour que les américains
puissent se faire vacciner
on en a beaucoup parlé anthony fois uci
avec lequel voilà c'était pas la grande
entente sur les derniers mois avec
donald trump confirmé dans son rôle de
conseiller sur le co vide alors que
précisément vous l'avez rappelé les
etats-unis sont confrontés à une hausse
très importante des cars notamment après
les fêtes de thanksgiving c'est une
bonne chose
son vous cette confirmation oui alors
faut-il a été très compétents à dans la
dans la gérance du cours n'avaient rue
c'est quelqu'un de très compétent qui a
été là qui est là aux états unis que les
américains connaissent depuis l'épidémie
du sida c'est quelqu'un qui était déjà
là au début de l'épidémie
dans 1981 ce qui est très important
c'est no tena c'est que hayden a nommé
un nouveau ministre de la santé qui est
en fait un ministre de la santé qui est
plutôt du côté progressiste de notes de
l'aide du parti démocrate
xavier becerra c'est quelqu'un qui est
pour limiter le profit des compagnies
pharmaceutiques c'est aussi quelqu'un
qui est pour le medicare forum qui était
la grande mesure de bernie sanders
donc tout ça on a envie de se dire ça
marche ça fonctionne dans la bonne
direction
maintenant j'ai envie de dire que
l'épidémie aura des conséquences
sociales et économiques qui sont
absolument énorme vous entendez parler
tout à l'heure avec la représentante du
gilet jaune c'est à dire que ici aux
etats-unis en effet comme vous l'avez
dit il n'y a pas de système de santé de
systèmes santé du système social où les
gens se sentent supporter sans soutenu
lorsqu'ils perdent leur travail et leur
assurance santé
cela veut dire que joe biden va
probablement débuter son mandat avec une
forme de gros boulet à la jambe
si j'ose dire familièrement et alors il
y aura il y aura il y aura une épidémie
qui sera énorme c'est à dire vraiment
encore une fois les canaris n'arrête pas
de s'accroître et puis en guise de sa 15
% peut-être de chômeurs 15 millions
d'américains qui ne peuvent plus payer
leur loyer
donc on est vraiment dans un pays qui a
beaucoup de difficultés en ce moment et
est donc joe biden commence à présidence
vraiment sous comme il l'a dit dans un
hiver très rude
alors ce mardi c'est un jour important
puisque tous les états on disait tout à
l'heure américains devront savoir
certifier leurs résultats électoraux au
moins fermé la porte à toute nouvelle
contestation
ça y est c'est définitif c'est une
sortie donc pour donald trump et une
élection pour rogers baydan oui alors je
crois que l'élection est tout à fait
confiant
hayden gagne le vote populaire de plus
de 7 millions de votes
c'est une des victoires les plus grandes
de l'histoire des états unis
et il gagne dans certains états clés à
aa avec une très petite avance a
finalement mais j'ai envie de dire que
rien n'est fini pour donald trump et
même que peut-être tout commence pour
lui
puisqu'on entend déjà dire que le jour
de l'inauguration de joe biden donald
trump a décidé de contenir un radis un
meeting avec ses supporters qui
concurrencera la télé donc
l'inauguration de joe biden donc je
pense que vraiment dans les quatre
prochaines années doit la trame sera
encore tout à fait présent multi n'est
plus président pour contrebalancer
vraiment toutes les initiatives de joe
biden réserve encore quelques surprises
si on est d'un compris merci tristan
cabello je rappelle que vous êtes donc
maître de conférences en civilisation
américaine à la john hopkins university
merci à vous
dans le reste de l'actualité l'échéance
se rapproche et avec elle le risque d'un
odile sur le break site pour le moment
les conditions ne sont pas réunies selon
londres et bruxelles
mais le gouvernement britannique fait un
pas aujourd'hui fait vers l'europe et
annonce retirer les dispositions
controversées de son projet de loi sur
le marché intérieur qui remettent en
cause le traité du break site
un geste qui s'apparente à une
concession faite à bruxelles où boris
johnson doit se rendre mercredi à trois
semaines de la rupture définitive avec
lieu le 31 décembre les discussions
commerciales s'enlise mais londres s'est
déjà préparée pour 2021 une année 2020
fructueuse en affaires pour le
gouvernement de boris johnson waleed bin
a mis un coup de téléphone attendu pour
un résultat tout autant attendu statu
quo dans l'après préc site
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson et la président de la commission
européenne
our souls amont der leyen ne sont
toujours pas en mesure de finaliser un
accord selon un dernier communiqué à
londres ce mardi boris johnson se montre
plus patriotes que jamais je suis très
optimiste mais je dois être honnête avec
vous la situation actuelle est très
délicate
nos amis doivent comprendre que le
royaume uni a quitté l'union européenne
pour être en mesure d'exercer un
contrôle démocratique dans la manière
dont nous faisons les choses
maître mot notamment du négociateur
britannique david frost souveraineté sur
terre et sur mer
objectif ne pas se laisser régir par les
possibles sanctions de l'union
européenne
notamment en matière de droit du travail
ou d'environnement alors une question
subsiste aujourd'hui comment le royaume
uni peut-il survivre son sens premier
partenaire commercial
ces derniers mois londres ne s'est pas
ménagé depuis le 1er février et le début
de la période de transition le
gouvernement de boris johnson a tenu à
s'assurer du soutien économique des
anciens territoires de l'empiré
britannique comme le canada c'est une
belle journée pour le canada royaume uni
se rassure c'est un jeu en juin dernier
le ministre du commerce australien s'est
félicité d'un accord de libre échange
avec son ami britannique en juillet
direction l'asie londres et ankara se
sont rapprochés pour de futures aux
échanges commerciaux de plus de 20
milliards d'euros sans oublier le plus
grand accord majeur post break site
conclu en octobre avec tokyo on disait
qu en voyons muni indépendants ne serait
pas en mesure de conclure un accord
commercial majeur ou qu'il faudrait des
années pour le conclure mais aujourd'hui
à prouver que les opposants avec thor
avec cet accord révolutionnaire façonné
à la britannique qui a été conclu en un
temps record prochain objectif continuer
à discuter encore avec washington en
les échanges entre le royaume uni et des
etats unis s'élevait à plus de 250
milliards d'euros à londres ambitieux
face à un bruxelles toujours déterminée
également à protéger ses intérêts à
l'image de son négociateur michel
barnier j'ai informé tous les états
membres lors de la réunion du conseil
des affaires générales aujourd'hui unité
totale nous ne sacrifierons jamais notre
avenir au profit du présent l'accès à
notre marché conditionné je collabore de
près avec david frost et son équipe pour
préparer la prochaine réunion entre
ursula von der leyen et boris johnson un
sommet européen est prévu ce jeudi et
vendredi le premier ministre britannique
est attendue
ce mercredi dans la capitale belge pour
un aller retour des plus scruté la dea
république démocratique du congo
s'enfonce dans une crise au sommet de
l'état deux camps s'affrontent dans le
pays depuis plusieurs jours les
partisans du président félix chiquet
selick est dit est ce son prédécesseur
joseph kabila
une bataille rangée qui a eu lieu à
l'intérieur du parlement aux congolais
ces dernières heures et la médiane
dimanche 6 décembre 2020 un discours de
chef de l'état en direct à la télévision
publique met le feu aux poudres
j'ai décidé de nommer un informateur par
ces mots félix tshisekedi sonne l'heure
du divorce avec le mot fort du pays
joseph kabila le président congolais met
donc fin à la coalition au pouvoir qu'il
formait avec la majorité parlementaire
de son prédécesseur un discours qui
déchire le pacte signé lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2010 8 et
qui réjouit les partisans nous avons
toujours souhaité ce divorce avec kabila
avec le front commun pour le congo
aujourd'hui le divorce est prononcé nous
sommes tous heureux aujourd'hui des
données des certificats de décès à la
coalition fcc casse le prêt peut donner
la paix la joie des scènes de joie dans
le camp présidentiel mais en face de la
colère pour la majorité parlementaire
pro kabila du front commun pour le congo
ce divorce violent gravement la
constitution lève csn et c'est sans
annuler ma concernée par les annonces
inconstitutionnel du chef de l'état les
rejette en bloc les cc note que les
conclusions unilatérale qu'en tire le
président de la république viole
gravement la constitution et celle des
prétextes pour liquider par
l'instauration d'un régime dictatorial
au service d'un pouvoir personnel des
institutions démocratiques établies le
pouvoir en place est désormais à la
recherche d'une nouvelle majorité
parlementaire faute de quoi il faudra
procéder à de nouvelles élections
la dissolution de la coalition disséquer
dit kabila fait craindre une crise
politique majeure en république
démocratique du congo depuis ce lundi
des affrontements ont lieu entre les
deux camps une bataille au sommet de
l'état au sein même du parlement avec
des scènes surréalistes ce mardi dans
l'hémicycle les protagonistes en sont
venus aux mains
la tribune a été saccagé et la séance
plénière n'a pas pu se tenir pour mettre
fin à ces affrontements la police a dû
intervenir et tiré des grenades
lacrymogènes
on n'est pas en parler nous sommes avec
stanis bouge acquerra tshiamala
journalistes reporters bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous c'est donc la fin de
l'union sacrée entre félix ticket et qui
c'est qui est dit et l'ancien président
kabila une décision unilatérale selon
vous en tout cas il faut dire que la
déclaration du président de la
république à l'issue des consultations
politiques il a dirigé depuis entre le 2
et le 25 novembre a lancé officiellement
ce dimanche 6 décembre dernier l'union
sacrée consacré donc la fin de la
coalition fcc cash c'est une décision
effectivement unilatérale parce que il
l'a prise sans avoir consulté son
successeur le président honoraire joseph
kabila et c'est ce qui est d'ailleurs le
partisan des joseph kabila dénoncer et
ils ont dit prendre acte de cette
décision du président tshisekedi et donc
il assume désormais la cohabitation
c'est qu'ils rachètent le temps du
président félix tshisekedi nécessaire
pour trouver retrouver une nouvelle
majorité en tous cas il faut dire que la
situation est elle est un peu volatil et
confie ce d'autant plus que hier lundi
il ya eu des troubles à l'assemblée
nationale tout simplement parce que la
présidente l'actuelle présidente qui
dirige la chambre basse du parlement
congolais l est du congo joseph kabila
elle avait convoqué une plénière et le
partisan de felice 5 et 10 ont tout fait
pour empêcher la tenue de cette plénière
c'est comme ça qu'ils aillent la bagarre
au sein de l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale est aujourd'hui donc c'est
mardi
le pétitionnaire donc le groupe des
faits litchi ce qu'elle dit les députés
qui sont avec felice ceux qui avaient
initié des pétitions qui visait chaque
membre du bureau de l'assemblée
nationale
et ces pétitions ont été déposés dans
des conditions un peu compliqué et ils
ont convoqué une plénière qui devait se
tenir aujourd'hui donc le pétitionnaire
la présidente actuelle de l'assemblée
nationale a aussi convoqué une plénière
qui devait se tenir aujourd'hui le des
partis se sont retrouvés ensemble dans
l'hémicycle ils se sont affrontés et
finalement la police est intervenue et
ce n'est que le les camps du président
tshisekedi qui a pu se réunir et
installé un nouveau bureau qui va
examiner le jeudi 10 décembre là le
pétition contre le le bureau actuel teny
par le pro kabila mais il faut dire que
rien n'assure que le président
tshisekedi arrivera à faire basculer la
majorité parlementaire
il faudrait donc attendre voir le vote
qui va se passer le jeudi dans le cadre
de l'examen de pétition qui vise le
membre du bureau actuel de l'assemblée
nationale est la dernière question on a
vu les réactions à la joie à la fois de
joie et de colère est ce qu'on peut
craindre une crise politique qui
pourrait durer l'onu d'ailleurs sont
donc s'en inquiète
on est déjà en pleine crise on est vous
compris vous savez la situation comeau
elle est très volatile on a déjà des
problèmes sécuritaires dans la partie
est du pays on a le problème aujourd'hui
économique avec l'actrice dit
coronavirus on a aujourd'hui les
problèmes de légitimité qui est toujours
évoqué parce qu'il faut dire que là le
résultat de l'élection du 30 décembre
2018 est toujours contestée par un des
candidats les candidats martin fayulu
qui réclament toujours la victoire à la
lèvre à l'élection présidentielle donc
il ya déjà cette crise de légitimité qui
existe
et puis à cette crise il ya maintenant
cette crise entre la coalition au
pouvoir donc le président tshisekedi et
son ex son ancien partenaire joseph
kabila
et puis le président tshisekedi pour en
arriver là il a fait alliance assez
cuillère étaient des opposants du
président kabila g site ici moïse
katumbi et jean pierre bemba
donc on est vraiment des gens pleine
crise si le des parties n'agissent pas
avec sagesse
il ya en tout cas risque et beaucoup des
craintes que la situation s'empire
davantage
merci stanis bouge acquerra tshiamala
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on reste sur le continent
africain au ghana au lendemain du
scrutin présidentiel le dépouillement se
poursuit un processus où haute sécurité
dans certains quartiers d'accra la
capitale
les résultats s'annoncent serrés entre
les deux favoris de chefs de d'état
sortant nana akufo addo et son rival
historique l'ancien président john
marama autour les partisans des deux
parties s'élèvent déjà la victoire de
leur candidat
et puis au liberia c'est un référendum a
valeur de test pour le président de
george weah depuis ce matin deux
millions et demi d'électeurs sont
appelés à approuver ou non huit
amendements à la constitution des
libériens qui doivent eux en même temps
choisir la moitié de leurs trente
sénateurs
le président aulas a voté dans la
capitale et en a profité pour appeler la
population à se déplacer massivement sur
pour ces scrutins
j'ai demandé à tous les libériens d'être
calme de venir au centre de vote
d'exercer leur droit de vote de choisir
leur candidat et de repartir en toute
tranquillité et à la fin de la journée
les résultats arriveront et ceux qui ont
été élus ceux pour lesquels vous avez
voté gagnerons mais ce pays a besoin
d'être en paix nous n'avons pas besoin
de détruire notre pays et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
dans quelques instants un point complet
sur l'actualité avec david kelly phare à
22 heures précises quant à moi j'aurai
le plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20
heures
[Musique]